les 1018 année charnière pour le golf
français le président de la ffb l'a
répété pendant ses voeux à la presse ce
mercredi 31 janvier dans huit mois la
ryder cup sera organisé pour la toute
première fois en france sur le parcours
du golf national à saint quentin en
yvelines
des équipes travaillent sur ce dossier
depuis la désignation officielle en 2011
travail de longue haleine chaque étape a
été balisé à réaliser les
investissements et le budget financier
maîtrisez donc nous jouons gros oui
parce que c'est l'épreuve la plus grande
dans le monde la fikin qu'on peut
atteindre jusqu'à un milliard de
téléspectateurs ce qui n'est pas rien
donc oui on joue gros dans ce sens là le
golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines accueillera
également fin juin sur le parcours de
l'albatros la 102e édition de l'open de
france de golf depuis l'année dernière
l'événement intégrer les rolex séries a
vu sa dotation passer de trois à sept
millions de dollars trois mois avant la
ryder cup la compétition devrait attirer
des têtes d'affiché
nous aurons une édition 2010 8
d'anthologie avec chaque paire de
nouveaux venus du continent américain et
les meilleurs joueurs au monde pour
venir tester ce parcours new look avant
d'accueillir septembre la halde cup
après cette année 2018 chargé la
fédération française de golf espère
booster le nombre de licenciés dans ces
678 club pour la saison prochaine
ils sont près de 400 14000 golfeurs
inscrits cette année